there are lots and lots of questions as
ever swirling around Boris Johnson
um
how do you react to what Chris Bryant
has to say I mean both the words that
Chris Brian used but also the
overwhelming sense of distrust and
um uh almost I suppose contempt from Mr
Johnson
before I answered that which I I'll
obviously answer Trevor you know because
I'm quite blunt spoken can I just um go
back to what Jonathan Ashworth said for
one second
um he was just in the job centers but
we've doing amazing stuff I was briefly
the skills Minister you know we have the
boot camps which you can get the
technical skills the hdv skills we've
got Kickstart to help people to write so
it's not just about the CV building I
just wanted to put that on the record
now regarding um I mean look we know
that Chris is as outspoken as I am but
on the other side of the fence and his
never like Boris and if anything there's
there's a real hatred from the left
um of Boris Johnson which I haven't seen
um since you know Thatcher's funeral to
be honest and I do think it's unfair I
think lines have been blurred where the
civil service is consent I mean for
um you know for some Civ previous civil
sermons to come out and publicly say
um that I you know was responsible for
bringing Boris Johnson down
um when you see that um you know part of
um the inquiry we hear that the head of
Ethics brought their own karaoke machine
to the Civil Service party yeah Boris
got the blame for Stuff
um the all these parties so I I would
like to see greater transparency not
only if the Civil Service have got this
orchestrator campaign and they are
trying to like stop our immigration
policy Etc I think we need to see more
transparency um with the Civil Service
and they declare their interests and
their relations with not only the media
but with Shadow cabinet as well
uh
I I I'm going to come back to to ask you
about uh the the what you said about the
civil services you mentioned several
times but just before we get that
is Boris Jones not responsible for any
of this I mean is he a sort of totally
innocent party
I I think if anything Boris has probably
been too trusting
um you know Boris uh foreign
along all of this and um just wandered
through and been you know the victim of
awful devious other people
now at the end of the day I mean I I
I've seen the hatred out there and the
vitriol that's why outside down history
I got frustrated you know the the left
walk got what they want and I think that
they need to leave Boris alone now but
it carries heavily pregnant just leave
him alone and what I really do question
Trevor is the timing of this
um so you're slightly you're being a bit
of a politician here you're sliding away
from my my basic question here whatever
you say about what's being said about
Boris Jones are you just saying that
he nothing he has done is worthy of
question or inquiry and he made no
mistakes
every prime minister and I'm not and I'm
not of the in the question here um
Trevor but every prime minister you know
should be questioned I mean this is why
I'm questioning our current prime
minister oversight and policies like
dropping annual welfare Bill and you
know I I will be a Critic I was with
Theresa May in our own party but with
Boris I do feel that no clearly that you
know he um he nobody's perfect without a
doubt um but there has seriously been at
least to hear you say that no but this
honestly there's been an orchestrated
campaign not only in my own party as
well because let's face it you know most
of my and fellow MPS are the one nation
to the left of the party they've got the
leader that they wanted
um in Rishi um they never accepted Boris
and ever accepted list trusts and they
are they're out of sync with the party
membership who uh big Boris fans
about the important point you made here
really which is about the role of the
Civil Service
um do you think it's right that the
cabinet office handed over boris's
Diaries to the Privileges committee and
as a result they ended up in the hands
of the police
I'm going with my personal view on this
my personal View is you know no and why
did it uh they should have at least let
Boris Johnson know
um that they had concerns but I go back
to the timing of this why all of a
sudden when the covert inquiry is
wrapping up and
um we saw with a um with a committee um
that um that didn't really um it wasn't
strong evidence I didn't feel I thought
Boris came out very well in the
committee
um so I just questioned the timing of
this as well to be honest well as you
say you've been pretty blunt I mean
you've been pretty blunt on WhatsApp and
um I think we've seen some of your
messages this week
um
you talked about
hypocrisy and sanctimony
um yeah do you want to tell us names and
names who are you talking about
well I mean the the person at the top
Simon Hall
um during um Teresa maze time you know
he was quite vitriolic on social media
had to block him in the end so the say
about Blue on Blue and um you know let's
keep this in house Etc but those who
throw the first stone you know that they
they
um that they need to make sure that
they're not deviant of doing the same
thing okay
who who else is in the enemy crew
I mean a lot of enemies I mean I have to
set the record straight with this um you
know we'd all much rather see the uh a
conservative government than a socialist
government
um with all their wokarati agenda so
um I mean I also blocked um the chief
whip Joe in that time
um who's now the chief whip so you know
these to me
sorry with with the greatest of respect
I mean you know I am I'm I'm a novice in
politics but I have to say well if you
want to see a conservative government
um yeah these WhatsApp messages bring
back Boris and all of that uh Rishi
always a bit weak uh all of the things
that you've been saying that they don't
seem like the best message to send to
the electorate if what you want to do to
get the conservatives re-elected
I I mean um look I
I Boris and Liz was a prime minister's
and you know the party leaders who I
supported I didn't support Rishi and um
you know that's life under Theresa May's
time we um I mean when Boris got elected
we saw members of the party who wasn't
happy with that but I mean ultimately we
do want to see a conservative
um elected and and if anything Trevor
what I'm trying to do I'm trying to be
outspoken which I can't be anything else
I'm a Yorkshire woman and I've been
brought up to be honest and blunt
um and if if anything I'm trying to you
know actually challenge some of the
policies that's coming out at the moment
too because I know what policies are
working in my area and actually to live
to deliver on our Manifesto commitments
okay just very quickly on yes or no so
being blunt Rishi sunak you want him to
be leader uh when you go to the next
election you're happy you'll get you're
you're gonna stick with it now
it's a change leader again now because
we'd have to go into a general election
and what we'll end up with 100c why
would you do that I want to see a
conservative government elected it
sounds like Richie's on probation have
any of the no confidence let us gone
gone in yet
um I haven't a clue you know you'll have
to understand you you haven't submitted
one have you I mean I know you've been
yeah
I'm very public look when I submitted
one over Theresa yeah I was public about
that so if I if I'd submitted one
um you know I would put it out there all
right look the last last point I just
want to ask you on behalf of my dear
friend and colleague Sam Coates
um when he broke the the story on on
Thursday you had to go at him I mean
honestly
I mean honestly you're impuning the
Integrity uh of one of the best
reporters around and with it the entire
sky crew I feel confronted no come on
Trevor I like Sam and um and you're
pretty decent as well but but come on we
know that the media that they're waiting
to you know stories to hear that the
party's falling apart but but we're not
you know if you look at I'm sure the
labor MP is WhatsApp you know you get
people who's happy and not happy and
it's been very leaky for the eight years
that I've been an MP so that's politics
okay
and by the way that bbbj hashtag I
didn't quite get what it meant
I'd bring back Boris Johnson of course
yeah I mean not that he wants to come
like I don't believe he does but Andrew
Andrew Jenkins we we really ought to do
this
we really ought to do this again thank
you so much for your time this morning
all the best have a good day bye-bye